Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday morning podcast and yeah. Yeah. Good.
I'm just checking out on you. Uh, I fucked up today. I, uh,
I forgot it was Thursday and I really wasn't doing shit today.
It's just one of those, uh, you know, you never had one of those days.
You didn't know it was Thursday. You always hit Thursday.
I thought it was Wednesday. Yeah,
I have one of those days and I was just fucking driving around no matter buddy.
Uh,
I was on my way out to a fucking Santa Monica to go smoke a cigar my first one
in like a month and a Andrew's like, you're gonna record today.
And I was like, record? And he's like, yeah, it's Thursday. I was like,
oh Jesus, there. So a, my apologies. My apologies.
I, I didn't check in on you. Yeah, I almost didn't, did you feel not loved?
You know, this is when you really think about it.
This is like the end of one of those feel good like Christmas movies or after
school specials. And like, we didn't think you were coming and then you're dead.
But I guess I didn't for most of you,
cause it's 10 26 La time as I'm recording this. So most of you guys back east,
it's central time.
I just fucked over half the people in this country as far as not checking in on
them as far as people that listen to this podcast.
So I'm basically saying that if this was a presidential campaign,
this would be the end of my campaign. I would have to a,
I'd have to try and fight it off. You know, Mr Bar, uh,
you, you tell the people
hello America,
you gotta to do a podcast every Thursday as last Thursday may even go to bought
it for the last year or so.
But last Thursday you actually did not check in on the east coast or the central
coast or the central part of the country, whatever it's called.
That's half the country.
Is this what the American people can look forward to if you are elected
president? Right, Debbie? I, you know what? Yeah, that's what
they can look forward to. You know, I didn't think I was going to get this far.
You know, I thought I was doing pretty good reading the shit off their, I'm,
excuse me reading this, the, uh,
the stuff off of the teleprompter and now I guess it's over.
So, uh, yeah, sorry to the east coast and the central areas.
Uh, my, no, it's our food supply and where a lot of, uh, I don't know,
a lot of the comedy and the cold weather comes from right.
So I apologize.
Jesus. Yeah.
I had my first cigar garden like fucking month and a was delish.
It was delicious. It was bad. It was bad. I fucking went to a, the cigar shop.
The guy was like, where you been? I was like, Hey, you know,
I'm down to two a month. He goes, ah, it's great. It's great.
A fucker went in there and it was just, I just missed it. I missed the smell.
I sound like fucking champ kind. I missed the way you smell.
And I went in there was hilarious.
We went to this place, Hollywood smoke out in, um,
out in Santa Monica and as I was driving down main street, great,
great fucking street out here in La, you know,
it's Saint Patty's day and it was just getting geared up.
It was like right around six 30,
like just the absolute fucking shit show that is Saint Patrick's day out here
and I should say in the United States,
absolute shit show the fucking light green plastic hats.
Those fuckheads are out, you know? And then you had the, the girls, you know,
of course horror ended up, you got to love that.
I still used to smoking hot fucking chicks was like,
let the same colored like is those green plastic hats,
like mini skirts with like thigh highs on. So I'm like, all right,
they're obviously slinging drinks. Maybe they're not, you know,
maybe they really, our attention horse, because I swear to God,
I don't know what the fuck you'd go out in public wearing something like that.
Four on a night when people who usually don't drink are going to get even more
hammered or I guess it's just amateur night.
And you're going to fuck and walk around with something like that. Well,
what's wrong with you? Jesus Christ.
Didn't your mother ever talk to you and sit you down and be like, listen,
there's nothing wrong with dressing like a who just do not do it on the
following holidays. St Patrick's Day,
New Year's and the 4th of July. Okay. Every other time. Thanksgiving. Okay.
You want to let the girls down a little bit? I don't have a problem.
Just don't say sit across to me at the dinner table cause you're still my little
girl. All right.
Unless they have some big like floral arrangement and you can know you can,
you can blow your boyfriend at that point. I'm not going to know,
but don't do it because you give your father a heart attack. Right.
Then they ever sit you down and tell you that shit. Well,
if they did, they didn't say it to these two. They were walking down the street.
I mean it's fucking unreal.
Like literally like hookers didn't dress like that when I was a kid. Um,
and it got me thinking like what the,
I always forget what the Fuck St Patrick's Day is.
So I'm going to Google that right now. Saint Patrick's Day. Here we go.
All right. We all know it's on March 17th.
Is this the thing where the guy chased the snakes out of the fucking town,
which just completely seems like a bullshit story to me.
Or was that some other guy was a flute odor.
That guy knows the Pied Piper and he got rid of the rats.
That was their problems back then.
It wasn't my phone died and my fucking Internet's too slow.
They literally had fucking reptiles and rodents
fucking spreading disease. That was aids back then. You know,
just a bunch of fucking rats would come to town and they'd bite one fucking
dude. They rats no to right that they fucking, they would,
they'd fucking bite this studly as guy there and he keasy cause fucking tag in
every winch in town. And next thing you know, right.
They're all coughing on their fucking husbands and that it was over. And then,
thank God some guy would come by, some guy who's probably, you know,
never got picked to go on the rape and pillage tours. You know,
that was like getting picked last in gym class back then. Right.
And all of a sudden he just finds his hidden talent.
He picks up for flute and he fucking dances around and everybody follows him out
of town. All the rats do. Right.
You know what's funny about that story is they never say,
once he gets out of town with the rats, like then what did he do?
You know, fucking throw the flute at them and then run back,
double back to town and hope that their little rat brains can't figure it out.
I mean they found it once, right? I don't know. All right.
Let's get case. St Patrick's Day is the day of the festival of Patrick.
Oh, thank you all though. That's sums it up.
It's a cultural and religious celebration held on the 17th of March.
The to the traditional death date of Saint Patrick who lived from three 85 to
four 61 that's a fucking good run for back then, Huh? He really was a saint,
not smoking, not drinking,
not messing with the who is what set. That's 70 let's see,
15 in 61 oh shit. We all know that. 76 years.
It's like living to 110 now and evidently he was the foremost patron saint of
Ireland. This guy was a fucking five-star general here.
St Patrick's Day was made in official Christian feast day in the early said,
well, what the fuck did St Patty do? Saint Patrick,
let's get back to this fucker.
Let's see why he became a Saint Patrick of violin redirects here. Oh Jesus,
doesn't he look miserable? Does anybody look happy in a stained glass window?
They always look like they got the fucking weight of the world on them.
What is wrong with my religion?
Jesus can as is that one picture of Jesus smiling, like cracking up,
hanging out with the apostles and somebody farted or something and they just
decided to paint them in that moment. They just never do it.
He must have had some fun. Right. Well, speaking of who is, didn't he fucking,
he laid down with the, what the fuck was her name?
That's a good whore name from back then, Huh? Ethel. Alright.
All right. Saint Patrick or this was a fifth century Romo.
Romano Brow. Oh No. Come on. Romano.
British Christian missionary and Bishop in Ireland known as the apostle of
Ireland. He's the primary patron saint of Ireland.
This all sounds like filibustering right now.
Like they're trying to kill a bill along with St Thou who gives a fuck.
He's also said that the dare, something the equal to apostles,
the date of Patrick's life cannot be fixed with certainty,
but on a widespread interpretation. He was an active,
he was active as a missionary in Ireland. Oh, we spread
the disease there. They celebrate this guy.
He brought that fucking horrific religion to them. And now look at him.
There's still drinking because of this guy's mission. Uh,
during the second half of the fifth century,
early medieval tradition credits in with being the first bishop of a something
primate of Ireland. Now he's hanging with an ape. All right.
I didn't know those gorillas and fucking, it's probably a chimp right now.
It couldn't be a chimp that fair skin. Well,
actually they all got fair skin there. Maybe that's where you go.
If you get a sunburn, the grill is like, yeah, fuck that. I need the heat, man.
You know stupid fucking chimps going up there with that fucking white face like
me. All right. According to the confederacy of Patrick,
when he was about 16 he was captured by Irish pirates.
You mean drunks from his home in Great Britain. Always from Britain. Now,
fuck is what?
This guy's guy was all over the place and taken as a slave to Ireland,
looking after animals where he lived for working on a farm.
They're really ramping this guy up where he lived for six years before escaping
and returning to his family. That's pretty amazing. How the fuck did he do that?
He needed a boat. People are incredible shaped. Any, probably swam it. Right.
Okay.
Yeah. It's probably why he lived so fucking long.
You do that one time. If you swim from Ireland back to fucking London,
wherever the fuck he was from. I mean, yes.
Basically you've gotten all the cardio that you need to do in your life out of
the way.
The guy was probably fucking shredded till he was like 66 then the last 10 years
were brutal. All right. After becoming a cleric, whatever the fuck that is,
that's either an accountant or something religious he returned to no,
I would click on it, but it's not highlighted, which makes me feel dumb.
I'm supposed to like automatically know what that means.
You returned to northern and western Ireland. Well that's a smart move.
You fucking leave the country, the dead enslaved you and then you come back
fucking Ian McShane. In later life he served as a bishop,
but little teddy bash, Mr Blackmagic. Um,
but little is known about the places where he worked by the seventh century.
He had already come to [inaudible].
Nobody knows anything about this fucking guy. He served as a bishop,
but little is known about the places where he was a fucking bishop.
It was kind of a bishop somewhere over there. Let me get to see.
Seem like he like he was a cobbler, a by the seventh century,
had already come out to be revered as the patron saint of Ireland.
Okay.
All right. I don't want to be a cunt on St Patrick's Day,
but don't you think there's a little gap in the information there?
This is like the story of Jesus where it's like, Yay.
He was a little baby and a,
they brought some gifts over and then he was 33 on a cross.
Some point he did some carpentry and he banged a horse. The other than that,
right. There's, there's nothing there.
This fucking guy was a bishop somewhere in western northern and western Ireland.
Little's known about that and then by the seventh century he was a patron saint
of Ireland. What did he do?
Name dating to Patrick's theories. Life. All right, let's get to his life.
At the age of 16 he was captured by hours. I already read this shit.
Did six years of captivity. He heard a voice story. Yeah.
He went crazy telling him that he would soon go home.
Sounds like it was malnourished to me and then that his ship was ready fleeing
his master. Oof. Kind of sounds like a Batman Robin relationship,
if you know what I mean. I think he was the gimp. He traveled to a pool.
He traveled to a port 200 miles away.
Yeah.
Traveled. Travel. How he took the subway. He made you walked where?
He found his ship and was difficult and with difficulty persuaded the captain to
take him in. Yay. Fucking blow him. That's about it. That's it.
The most difficult persuasion. Right. Unless, you know,
he was happy to be with his master earlier. I don't know. This all sounds like,
I don't know, some sort of gay love triangle to me, after three days sailing,
they landed presumably in Britain. You know what?
I'm glad we drink on this fucking day. You know,
if you're going to be that fucking vague,
this is like why you feel the next day you have to get went and what'd you do
last night? I don't know. I was kind of a drunk in a western La and that, uh,
the cops came and I fucking heard this voice in my head saying that there was a,
uh, a ship waiting for me, you know? Yeah. What do you mean you called Uber?
Yeah, basically. All right. I apologize for all of that. Happy St Patrick's Day.
Everybody. A lot of you probably still up drinking,
getting shit faced and all that. Um, why not?
Okay.
Why not?
I missed all the march madness. Um, I don't watch the first fucking rounds.
You know what I mean? Every once in a while this upset there's an upset. Right?
You should just watch holy cross. They fucking disappoint somebody every year.
Send everybody going home crying. I'm going to try to watch on say a but a,
I'm busy over the next couple of days, but, um,
I had been watching my Bruins again and after that big fucking hot streak,
I start watching them and then they start losing. So, uh,
they're playing the kings this Saturday and uh,
I'm going to tape the game cause I feel like if I don't watch it live,
they gonna win and then I could watch it and I can enjoy it. But, uh,
I'm starting to, you know, ramp back up with the hockeys.
The playoffs are coming and I watched the kings versus the Dallas fucking ah,
um, get ready for a bond.
Verner and the king's just came out and gave him the old right there.
Fred gave him two fucking quick ones. Then, um, you know,
and I was sitting at home, you know, mocking, announces go out there,
right elbow. The next goal as well. Support and goal is gay.
Obviously KCC go up three, nothing or that's the stars. Cut It in half.
We can do the fucking math when the numbers are that low.
So what you got to love about hockey, you know,
the numbers are always nice and love. It's very rare to see it go over.
You never really have to count over five.
I think that's why it appeals to me that in the fighting, right?
So the stars score next and it's two to one and then they dead. You thinking,
okay, here we go. We got a game and then Bam, fucking they score again. Three,
two, one after one. The next thing you know,
I go out and make myself a grilled cheese sandwich.
I come back and it's fucking five to one. However,
that doesn't mean that's how it's going to go in the playoffs.
And those are two of my favorite teams out in the West.
Of course the Bruins are always my favorite, but are the kings.
The stars are really fun to watch. So I'm getting psyched for the, uh,
for the hockey playoffs. Speaking of which, um,
I have an open invite to do the great Joe Barton x puck off podcast and uh,
I'm going to try to do that sooner rather than later. But, um,
I'm excited about that and I got to get into the whole march madness thing.
So that's basically, that's basically my life. Right. And, um,
so you're probably thinking like, well bill, you know,
I know you tell jokes at night, you have to know when you fucking spots are,
how did you forget it was Thursday? Well,
all freckles here at a really fucking busy day because a, they started a,
they started making my, my little baby gym,
my little get and shape gym, get in shape, girl gym at the back of my, uh,
garage. And uh, so I had to clear everything out.
And unfortunately I had to put my truck in storage for the next couple of weeks.
I was only going to take them like two, three weeks,
which means six months in construction talk, um, for them to, uh,
to complete this project. And uh, I,
I can't tell you how fucking sad I was dropping that truck off.
It's unreal. Every time I look at that truck or I start driving it,
I have this big goofy fucking grin on my face. Like, yeah, be here.
Like when people drown, you know,
after you go through the horror of drowning, right as you go to pass out,
like all this dopamine is released.
And I guess when they find you underwater and your cement shoes,
you have this goofy smile on your face provided they didn't drop in like a
thousand feet of water on your head didn't fucking explode. Um, you always,
I guess have this fucking like when they find scuba divers and underwater caves,
um, you know, cause they get lost. I mean, Jesus Christ,
talk about that most fucking horrifying thing ever. Fucking going in there.
I mean, Jesus Christ, what do I mean, what do you do when you're underwater?
You can't drop breadcrumbs. How'd he get back?
There is no fucking,
that is the most fucking insane thing you could ever do.
Let's go explore some underwater caves.
Can you imagine that shit and then you fucking get lost.
Wow. Dude, this gotta be stories of people that survived.
I want to hear that mind. Fuck. How the fuck do you keep yourself calm?
Cause you know you're going to panic and then you're going to start breathing
faster and that fucking Shit, you know?
Oh my God, I don't know what I would do.
I would just get my flippers going as fast as I could and try to knock myself
out against the fucking wall.
Okay.
You know, and you couldn't because you're under water.
You can't even fucking knock yourself out. What do you do then?
I think you just swim up to a big fish and give it the finger and hope it
fucking puts you out of them, out of your misery. Um,
the fuck was I talking about? Fuck did I get onto that?
I was talking about dropping, dropping the truck off. Yes. So, um,
I gotta be honest with you man. Like I like no new cars do it for me.
They're all the fucking same. Pisses me off. You know,
cause my car is getting old man. My car was like eight years old.
Granted seven or eight years old. Yeah.
It's going to be eight years old since I've had it October this year. And um,
I've maintained that thing, you know, I take it back to the dealership.
I have them do the whole thing. I pay through the fucking nose and uh,
it runs like a God damn top. It runs like a fucking top to the point.
I'm not even nervous about saying it, but the interior's going to shit, right.
The steering is all fucking worn out and um,
but I love the car because I can park it anywhere and I don't give a fuck if
anybody drives into the thing. Um,
but my buddy who I smoked cigars with,
he's got this fucking Cadillac and I really like it, you know,
and I like them more than the fucking,
I dunno everybody out here is Lisa's a fucking
okay.
The BMWs, the fucking every other day
Douche has one of those out here, so I don't want to get one of those. And uh
hm.
Audi's a cool, you know why they got Audis?
Audis is like the fucking bill Bellacheck draft pick.
That's the second round guy or the guy who gets picked in the third round and
has something to fucking prove. Like, I feel like Audi has something to prove.
You get more bang for your buck.
We're fucking BMW and a fucking, you know.
Okay.
Mercedes,
they like the first round draft pick holding out for a fucking bigger contract.
Fuck those cars. Right.
Okay.
Well I'm German too, man. I'm mostly German. I should be fucking,
I guess Audi's German too, right? I Dunno. But, um,
I like buying American shit though,
even though it's probably built in fucking Mexico or Turks and Caicos,
whatever the fuck they build them now. Um,
okay.
So I'm thinking like, all right, well my buddy's got a Cadillac.
I can't go out and get a fucking caddy pull up next to him.
He looked like single white female freckles over here. Right. So I go,
what about the fucking Lincoln mark five or whatever.
Don't they still make that car? So I go to the fucking Lincoln website.
When the fuck did they dibble that car or did it just not keep up?
That thing used to be the answer to Cadillac and that you can get one for like
35 grand,
which is not, it's still 35 grand. But I thought would they would,
it would be like up there like with the caddies,
like the caddies or like, you know, they,
they kind of end where all the high end BMW's and Mercedes fucking end. Right.
So I figured the Lincoln was going to be up. Like I thought I was going to,
you know,
be like some luxury car and this is a thing nobody drives one of those,
which should be great. So I got something a little different. It's got nice,
you know. Nice fuck. That's a great old man car. A fucking Lincoln, you know,
you drive around in it. People look at you, they gotta look at that guy.
He's probably a member of the NRA. I don't want to fuck with that guy.
It's a fucking, it's a classic old man car.
And uh, I don't know if I'm looking at the wrong model,
but every they have like, all they have is fucking SUV now.
And then they have like the, uh, I don't know.
I looked at the car and it was like,
you ever see somebody used to go to the gym every day and then they don't
anymore. And you can see, you can kind of see,
yeah.
Like, Oh, yeah, that guy used to work out and now we, uh,
now he gets like three appetizers before he dies into the fucking,
I'll speak to that dude. I, when I dropped the car off,
I had to wake my lovely wife up and she, you know, followed me over and uh,
it was early in the morning. She's not a morning person. Right. And uh,
so I told her I'd take around, go to breakfast. She of course eats healthy.
Um, okay.
You know, still looking gorgeous. And I,
first thing I see on the menu was a eggs benedict with fucking pulled pork and
you know, came with potatoes and like an asshole.
I ordered it and I have been paying for it the whole day.
I barely been able to keep my eyes open all day for all you youngsters out
there. That's what fucking happens to you when you get older young dude, you,
you know, you got a low miles on your digestive track,
you can go eat something fucked up and then go play Frisbee football,
whatever the fuck it is. You kids do go fly a drone around an airport.
And freak out some pilots, whatever it is that you guys do,
whatever you wacky kids do, put on a virtual reality fucking helmet and a,
I dunno,
take video of you fucking next door neighbor and then you're fucking bagging
them. And then you feel weird when you see and when you go to get the mail,
whatever it is you kids do. Um, yeah,
you can do that after eating fucking McDonald's. I, I cannot,
I can't.
We actually postmate at McDonald's the other day and like fucking 1230 at night
and I gotta tell you it was fucking delicious. And the next day I woke up,
I was like,
did I get into a bar fight last night and lose horrifically like was I the guy
like laying, you know,
those old school bars where they didn't even have stools and they just had that
brass rail for you to put your foot up on.
You ever see a guy who ends up like in between the bar and that thing while
there's like three people kicking him, you know,
that that classic guy in every other bar in fucking Boston.
I felt like that happened to me and they just kicked me right in the stomach,
the entire fucking beat down. I'm, what did I order? You didn't ask.
I got double cheeseburgers
and the fucking large fry and I enjoyed every second of it and I distinctly
remember at least three times Nia looking over at me telling me to slow down.
I fucking ate like an I, you know,
I ate like a guy that fucking ordered out for McDonald's. So as you can tell,
my gym can't get here soon enough. Um,
I ordered, I ordered all of my shit from rogue fitness.
Thanks a lot for not fucking hooking me up and recognizing my h level celebrity
status. She could at least giving me a fucking one kettlebell.
He couldn't even do that. Well I gotta Beg you guys,
you know I love about it is I don't owe you anything and if you're fucking
weight sharp and they're too heavy, I'm going to trash it. Um,
I ordered the weights and I wanted the colorful ones and Nia tease me out of it.
She actually used like some sort of like Jedi mind trick with a little bit of
fucking homophobia. She's like,
those are the ones you're going to get that rainbow color. She goes,
they look a little corny. I go, I like them. They're different.
Like the 40 fives a blow and then the m 30 fives or a night,
a nice lime green. And then the 20 fives a yellow.
I didn't think it seemed more, it didn't seem a feminine to me.
It seemed more like a Fisher prices first. Uh,
I know your first fucking dumbbells. I don't know.
So she teased me into getting the fucking Manley wants, you know,
like the Clint Eastwood once the old school fucking once.
So I got those in a weight bench and I get a little fucking retractable rack
with my pull up bar and a, I dunno, we'll see what happens.
And you know, it's funny,
as I have the ability to do squats with this thing if I want to.
And uh, like most guys, I hate to in legs, I don't know what it is, it's just,
it's not sexy. You know what I mean? You fucking do anything in the upper body.
You know, all you do is you do like one set,
you spend the next 20 minutes flexing in the mirror,
but with your legs you just like, oh fucking hurts. You know, and you just,
you really don't get anything out. You know, there's no ego boost to legs,
right? If you fucking never miss leg day, like your, your,
the level of discipline that you have. I have to respect that.
I put you right underneath people that have the balls to explore an underwater
cave in. Um, all right. And with that, let's uh,
let's read a little bit of advertising. God knows I won't be rogue fitness.
Some mother fuckers. Where did they get off blowing off and nobody liked me.
Can you fucking believe that every God Damn Day you're on TV and they show
somebody, right?
Somebody used to be on Charles in charge is getting a new fucking deck.
You know, he's getting his dream deck and he's go, oh my God,
I can't believe you guys did my wife set this up all they asked for a couple of
fucking,
you know, barbells, let me get back to me.
Okay.
It's coming off real cold, rogue fitness. Um, anyways,
by the way, rogue fitness. According to them, all of this shit is made in,
made in America. Now, granted they might be using illegal immigrants,
you know, with welding masks or whatever the, however the fuck you make weight,
you know, you know,
they're doing that and making horseshoes and like fucking 20 other things.
Pull bastards. Um, you don't what Donald Trump wants him out of the country?
I'll tell you. Um, all right. Mian D's.
Everybody. Oh. [inaudible] I'm a fucking fat shit.
Booboo do do, if I keep eating McDonald's, I won't even get to wear underwears.
Uh, but if I do,
I could dry off my balls and fucking flush them down the toilet in a bathroom
stall. I always say bathroom stall now. Okay.
Whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear.
Unless you're like a fucking filthy animal and known. Understood.
Guys that don't wear underwear cause I swear to God,
no matter how much you shake your Dick after you take a Piss,
no matter how much you fucking YPN, stick a whole box of cleanups up there,
there's always going to be a little tinkle. You know what I mean?
You never realize it to that day. You go fucking,
you know you go commando and then you're walking out of the bathroom.
You're like, why is one of my calves sweating? Oh that's right.
Right. You need it that Oh boat boat. Biondi sorry ladies.
But that's the way it works. All right. Okay.
But instead of making a statement like Superman's tight under his clothes,
under his everyday clothes, your,
your underwear is probably boring me undies is here to change that.
I think there was a joke in there and I blew it. Um, all right.
Every pair pair of me undies is made from sustainable source to modal model,
a fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing can describe the fit and the feel of money on this yet.
We're still going to have more copy.
I love how you can't fucking describe it yet.
I still have to read 20 more fucking paragraphs for this shit,
but why don't you try them on?
You'll understand while they're called the world's most comfortable underwear,
and if you don't love the first pair of me undies, they're free.
No questions asked. Hey, did you not like that thing? Keep it.
I never understood the line of that copy. Me Only said,
why can I send it back to you? The soiled underwear. You know,
you guys should take it back for your failure. All right.
Mandy says dozens of styles and limited edition prints.
That's so stupid to help you make a statement like there.
Jordan's a limited do you got to fucking be on these threes?
A people lining up outside the store to help you make a statement with your
underwear, whether you can see them or not. Remember Superman. All right.
Shipping is free in the United States and Canada and you can save up to $8 a
pair with Biondi with the Mandy subscription plan. Get the subscription
plan or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order when you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar that's
[inaudible] dot com slash burger for 20% off of your first order. Hey,
Mandy's dot com slash bar all right, tracker,
SMAD Caz, smart phones, smart homes, technology has made everything fucking
ah,
but losing your stuff makes smart people feel stupid and it causes you to yell
at your dog tracker. Makes losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is a coin size device that locates misplaced keys,
wallets, bags, computers, anything in seconds.
Just pair tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find its precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy. I swear to God, this is made by the Illuminati. I know it is.
They're getting your e's. Then the,
you put a chip in your dog and your fucking put something else on your phone.
Hey, you know what are you special? It's fucking jam. One in,
right behind your right ear. Ah, lose your phone.
Press the button on tracker and your phone rings.
Even when it's on silent with over 1.5 million devices.
Tracker has the largest crowd, uh, gps network in the world.
So lost item shows. So your last item shows up on a map,
even if it's miles away, never lose anything again with tracker.
Listen to the this show.
Get a special discount of 40% off your first tracker device.
Go to the tracker.com and enter Promo code bar.
The hardest thing you'll have to ya'll ever have to find is their website.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo code birth for 40% off.
Again, that's tracker.com Promo Code Bar. And lastly, but not leastly hang on,
I gotta get a drink of water here. Fucking smoke that goddamn stick here.
Um, oh, stamps.com everybody, our good old friends, all dependable.
Like if this was Sanford and son, stamps.com would be Grady. All right.
stamps.com um,
trips to the post office are never convenient. You know,
unless you're banging some broad there, right. And she likes to fuck at work,
then it's real convenient.
So why not get postage right from your desk with stamps.com stamps.com uh,
it even gives you special postage discounts you can't get at the post office,
including first-class mail, priority mail express international,
and more using your own computer or a friend's if they're cool and a printer,
buy and print official US postage for any letter or package than just hand your
mail to the male man, not the male woman, the mailman,
or drop it in a mailbox. It's that easy.
No wonder over 500,000 small businesses are already using stamps.com I use
stamps.com anytime I send out anyone in my fucking posters right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name, birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a including postage and a
digital scale. Don't wait, get to a get started with stamps.com
today. Go to stamps.com before you do anything else, click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarburthatstamps.com uh, enter bar.
So all Billy fucking drum stick. I got these, uh,
these new Zildjian cymbals, right? Um,
the fuck do you spelled Zildjian where are they?
Oh, they got these new fucking symbols, right?
That they actually made. They almost look like,
you remember those Mesh shirts that people wore in the eighties? Um,
they look like that, right? And uh,
they thought it'd be this cool new sound and it barely made a sound.
So they thought it was a,
they were a failure until somebody figured out that they're actually great for
practicing. And if you can't, you know, play loudly.
So I obviously didn't make a drum room,
so I had my little practice pad kit and now I've got symbols on them and they're
fun. They're the fucking shit. They're still loud as hell.
I can't play with my wife is home, but you know, she's always working.
So when she leaves, I sit down and play and I've got to admit, man,
they're fucking awesome. And you know, a couple hundred bucks,
it's not that bad. Nice and fucking cheap. You get to play along.
And even though they got all the fucking holes in them,
you could still bounce to sticks. Work on you. A little technique there,
you know, be a little fucking maniac. Whatever the hell it is you want to do.
Where the hell are they? Oh, then I called sound off. What the fuck are they?
God dammit.
I got to get the names of these things cause they're fucking awesome.
Look at this shit. I should have fucking said I do. Yeah, they,
they wouldn't give any free shit where they, I want free shit man.
I've come to that point. I want some free fucking shit. God dammit.
I'm gonna stop talking about Apple. So I'm gonna Start Small. All right.
Zildjian l eighties series LV three eight low volume symbol box set.
Look at this right here. You can order them right here online for 200 bucks.
I got fucked. I didn't know that.
God Damn it. I spent like 70 extra bucks. What a dope.
Ah, Jesus cried looking at it.
I had to fucking wait like a month from to come in. What is wrong?
I just don't like computer. I should try.
I should try to like computers more every once in awhile. Oh Shit.
It's already 34 fucking minutes, isn't it? Um,
and it's late at night and I got an early day tomorrow. So, uh,
was there anything else that I wanted to talk about? You know,
I'm so sick of people talking about their fucking brackets. I don't give a fuck.
I'll do it. By the way, I was a, he's an La story for you.
I was out in my car the other day, right? And all of a sudden,
like four fucking police cars just went flying by me.
And then this and right above me there was like,
I swear it seemed like another four fucking helicopters.
And I was like, what the fuck? The fuck is that? Right?
So I go home later and I watched the goddamn news and some fucking
had stole up, stolen a police car.
So the first fucking one that went by,
I never saw the guy was actually the fucking dude they would chase.
And I thought it was a bunch of them going and they who, I swear to God,
if they had been doing like fucking 90 miles an hour down this road,
that was like a 30 mile an hour zone, right. So, uh,
you know, they fucking follow the guy, Yada, Yada, Yada and all that.
He won't stop. They spin him out, they won't stop.
And then finally this fucking cop in like the police SUV just fucking gives them
the old right there, Fred to the fucking driver's side door,
just totally just cave this thing in. And I was just like,
oh Jesus Christ, that's at least a separated shoulder full life.
And uh, I guess they ended up shooting the guy. I mean, you know,
I mean at some point you, you know, you have to use deadly force.
Somebody driving 90 miles an hour around just regular people, you know,
if he was around irregular people, that's understandable.
You can go up on the sidewalk. Nobody cares. But he was around,
he was around regular people. They spun him out. He wouldn't do they, you know,
they fucking removed his shoulder with an SUV.
And this motherfucker's still going at it and I just sigh, you know,
we get what you're communicating. You don't want to be here anymore.
And then that was it. Fucking unreal man gave me the creeps.
Seeing somebody drive by knowing like this was the last like fucking 30 minutes
of their life. Unbelievable. But having said that,
I would rather go out like that than get lost in an underwater fucking cave.
God Damn it.
If there were like a documentary on this gotta be something I got lost in an
undo, you know, and you know the deal,
like it's always like they tell those stories and the guys like they're playing
the creepy music and it was like, yeah,
me and a buddy of mine decided that we were going to go explore some underwater
caves and they just keep, you know,
they start doing the reenactment and they just keep cutting the of,
they show two divers, but they just keep cutting back to the same guy.
And after like the third time they go back to and be like, all right, oh,
obviously the other dude fucking died or a,
he got some serious fucking brain damage.
Something happened because he's not in the documentary.
What the fuck is going on? And sure enough, you know,
then there's always that creepy thing of like, well,
how come you lived in your friend? Didn't I know what happened?
You fucking panicked and you grabbed his fucking regulator,
whatever the fuck you called it, right?
And then you had all the air and he didn't have any and you got to go to bed
with that every night, you know? I don't know.
I don't what the fuck I'm talking about. All right. Listen, I have to go to bed.
I got some shit to do. I apologize. Happy Saint Patrick State. Everybody.
I hope you guys had a great one. A,
I hope you guys have a wonderful fucking weekend and I know there was something
else I wanted to talk to you about.
Something that happened to me early in my week.
Maybe on Monday, maybe I'll remember it Monday. I'll write it down. Okay,
that's it. Have a wonderful weekend. Your cuts and I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible] is
[inaudible].
Let's get down to the, uh, the podcast question of the week. As I said,
well, send these things into me and I never have them in front of me,
which causes long awkward pauses. Alright. Uh,
okay. Here's the podcast question number one, Bill,
what does an east coast transplant do on St Patrick's Day?
You're already know what it's like in Boston and in New York City.
Is it the same or does no one in La really care? Um,
I might've mentioned this on my other podcast.
I do not participate on St Patrick's Day. Actually went out last night,
you know, I went out,
I got myself a couple of Jameson's and I had a corn beef sandwich and that's it.
I do not go out on Saint Patrick's day is a sandwich or night.
Same Way New Year's eve is a bunch of people who, uh, don't know how to drink,
drink way too much. They wear green plastic hats.
They sing the fucking net green alligator and along nick goose all these stupid
ass fucking songs. And uh, I dunno, it's, it's,
it makes me sad. St Patrick's Day. It makes me sad because, uh,
when I look at what the Irish culture has chosen to focus on,
it's no wonder we're all a bunch of angry psychopaths
that uh, even when we go to therapy, evidently it doesn't affect us.
I don't know if anybody else Irish out there like you have to go to a wedding
that's not an Irish wedding.
I went to a Jewish wedding and I went to a wedding a long time ago.
This girl who was a Pakistanian and the weddings, they were beautiful.
It was really a nice environment.
It was all about the union of two people who were going to spend their lives
together and a celebration of that and you go to an Irish wedding and this is
the main focus is, is like when you get the advise like dog is it see it open.
Really, I'm fucking there. That's what it is.
That's all people give a shit about is can I go there and get fucked up for,
for no money. That's the big question.
And then people get hammered and then resentments come out and then inevitably
there's going to be a fight.
Maybe that's why I like hockey reminds me of the weddings I went to when I grew
up. So getting back to your question now,
people do celebrate Saint Patrick's day out here. There's a,
I go to this place out,
Tom Bergen's down on a Fairfax just south of Wilshire because it's a,
it's a mellow place. They got a jukebox in the corner that play in music,
but it's like background. It's not like you're going to listen to this,
whether you want to or not,
sort of martial law sound system that they have and all these other bars where
you got to sit there and scream at the person next to you how much you like they
scream on ESPN, look at me just tying everything together that's fucking weak.
So yeah, no, they definitely celebrate it.
Obviously it's not the way it is back east. There's not a bunch of,
uh, there's not as many Irish people out here, but they're definitely out here.
They definitely do drink and they wear the green hats and all that type of shit.
But, uh, there's no parade. There's no bagpipes. There's just the booths.
We did this just,
just basically bare bones to the couple of corn viz sandwich just in the corner
and it's 12,000 kegs and a bunch of plastic crap.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
such right now. I did a show in Dublin, Ireland.
All the crowds were great,
but I gotta tell you those fucking people in Ireland are the funniest.
I can't even explain. I sweat it. Well,
there's something about like when I go through Great Britain and Ireland,
it's like Scotland and Ireland.
They like the knuckleheads that I grew up with and when I go to London,
London is like,
it was kind of like all the people that I met when I went to New York that were
from Boston. So they, they did move away from where were from,
but they still brought that thing with them because people in London are
hilarious.
But I was doing a show Dublin on Monday night at the,
the, the vicar Ficker street theater or something.
Just this awesome venue and a, anyway, so it was,
it was on a Monday night and it's a really hard night to try and sell tickets
and these people showed up in force and I can't even tell you how it
there, they were fucking hilarious.
Like I was on stage and there was this thing I was talking about about people
hugging their kids and now they could, pet is a good thing,
but if you do it too much, you could potentially make a week or so. I mentioned,
and I'll,
I haven't tell him this story for like six to eight months and I've been saying
how that, you know, my mother wasn't a hug,
hug her and didn't hug us when we were kids and people just listen.
It's just a small detail that leads to this other part that I want to talk
about. So I've said that line
uneventfully that's even a fucking word with no,
no issue whatsoever for like six months.
Now I'm in fucking Ireland and I just throw that laden out there like I'm not
even thinking about it and say, yeah. He said, you know,
my mother didn't hug me when I was a kid and I'm getting ready to see the next
sentence. And like 15% of the crowd goes, ah,
I'm not even doing it the way they did.
It just collectively broke my body.
It was just such the classic fucking,
it was like that Boston Irish thing that I grew up with distilled to its purest
form with actually real Irish people were I,
you'd almost have to be there to fucking understand what was behind it.
It was like I opened the emotional door,
just a crack in automatically. It's just,
they just bust your balls about it. Like, yeah, you fucking, you know what?
Like you think they, I think we got hugs.
Your freckled can't shut the fuck up and tell the judge I can't even, it just,
I, I've been trying to, I've tried to explain it to Nia. She laughed,
but it still, yeah, you kinda had to be there and then,
you know, so I laughed like when my fucking trying to get your sympathy,
I'm trying to get through this mess. Next part you assholes.
And the whole crowd fucking laughs. And then like a half hour later,
what I had done when I was over there was I bought a bunch of DVDs with me. Um,
like just the, uh,
basically the DVD itself with this little paper thing.
And I was just handing them out to people cause I'm trying to get them to show
other people, you know,
when I'm out there so I can keep coming back. Basically trying to get them to,
uh, spread the word on my comedy. And then someone's just like,
well why don't you just put it on Spotify? You're dumb. Fuck. And I'm like, Eh,
cause I'm old. Alright. I feel like I have to bring the hard copy.
So I tell these assholes
that I'm given them free DVDs at the end of the show
and I'm halfway through that Spiel,
telling them that they're getting a free DVD. All right.
And I'm in the middle of it and I hate this guy in the back of the crack goes,
oh fuck off.
I don't even think I even explained what I was doing.
I don't know if I had gotten to the part where they were free.
I don't know what the fuck.
Oh it was the fact that I was trying to once again go to a nice place where hey,
you know, I really appreciate you guys coming out.
This really means a lot to me and I want to keep coming back here cause I think
you've got a great comp country or whatever. And I just,
just opening the door that much. Oh fuck off.
So I finally just looked at, I went, Jesus Christ,
they were already left and I was like, you know what, I've played in 20,
almost 22 years as a comedian.
I've played in front of some miserable motherfuckers but you guys,
and they were already laughing,
are the most miserable fucking cops I've ever been in. And they loved it,
absolutely loved it. And um,
it killed me that I couldn't go out drinking with the crowd.
Cause I had a fucking go a had an early flight before. So
[inaudible]
guy and a fan who was never has never has any problems downloading your podcast.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I'd send you a free fucking DVD if you gave me a fucking address money.
You can't, you just can't.
I what's with the podcast download downloaded what is with you? It's not me.
My website is fine. It's never crashed.
Okay.
Anyways, he say,
I mentioned that because in the comments every week your listeners seem to think
there is some correlation between not being able to download it and being
affected. Um, first this Eaton, they're actually quoting one of my jokes.
If you haven't seen the joke, okay,
if you think I have a bunch of homophobes I did this bit called what do you
effect? And it had to do with, uh, it was actually anti homophobia,
although some gay people, the second they hear fag,
they stand up and yell homophobe and what run out of the room. Um,
I call that a story Seattle. Um, anyways. First.
This email isn't meant at all to get you to sensor or to be PC.
I like your stuff a lot.
Your point of view is hilariously balls out and usually different from the same
old comedy cliches,
but I'm curious with all the hundreds of things you and your listeners identify
as gay,
do you really still think most gay guys are the old stereotypes on most sitcoms
and in Leno's monologue jokes out? Jesus, you're going to talk down to me, sir.
Is that what it is? Is that what you're going to do here? Yeah, I think that,
I think you all go like the phone is hair.
Don't you guys sing everything? He's really rarely. Of course.
I don't think that. It's just funny and not to mention when we say stuff is gay,
it has nothing to do with homosexuality. Okay. When you said, you know,
you like this lamp, now it's fucking gay. Why is it gay? Look at it. It's just,
it's gay. All right. It just means it's lame staying. You know what it is.
It just gives you that, you know, anything that gives you that feeling of, um,
it's not love. I don't know what it is.
Uh, what I, you know, I don't even know what the word is.
What does that fucking word when you're just,
you know, when you just sit there, your girl like you,
you take a night off from work and you're sitting there with your girl and she,
you know, and she, you know, if you rent a, a video,
whatever the fuck you do now, snap your fingers and an appears in your TV.
I'm so fucking far behind. I can even use an iPad. I don't know.
I don't know what you kids do nowadays. Back in the door, you went to a day,
you went to a fucking video store, all right?
And pretended to want to watch a fucking romantic comedy when you really want to
walk through those saloon doors and look at the poor enough, right.
That fucking feeling when you come home,
when you're sitting there and you've made some food and your girl gets all
excited and it's like any nice, you know, he's just dies. You know,
it does just enjoying each other. Whatever that fucking feeling is that's gay.
Okay. But I don't know what to call that fucking feel. And to me that's gay.
Alright?
Now every once in a while I'll look like a fucking chair or a lamp or somebody
asked me to do something and I get that same feeling like, that's fucking gay.
I don't want to do it. It has nothing to do with gay people. All right?
So don't get sensitive on me, sir. I know you're not.
I know this person's not being a dick. So anyways, he says, uh,
do you guys think we're all, uh,
the gay guys and the old stereotypes of Sitcoms, uh, or in Leno's monologues?
Um,
is it because the ladies make you watch dope era and the view,
the view hags who just love having gay guy girlfriends because they love
emasculating men any frigging way they can. Oh, I get this guy.
This guy's a bear. He's one of those gay guys.
You know the kind of guy you're hanging out with on the construction site and
somebody picks on you, right? And this guy comes to your rescue,
fucking turns them all into a pretzel, you know, you're like, Jesus Christ,
that's a fucking
guy's guy.
And then all of a sudden he just sits down and there's just something about the
way he's crossing his legs. You're like, what the fuck is with this dude?
All right. And then one day he just says, listen,
I've got something to tell you.
I see what you're saying. I get it.
That's like me being a German Irish guy and I'm like,
we're not all Nazis and drunks, but you know,
if you put on the history channel or if you go on and say, Patrick, Patty's day,
you know, you sir, you're defined by the worst of your group.
Unfortunately, this kind of how it works. Um, but no, I don't,
I don't obviously don't think people like that I saw will and grace than they
are both ends of the spectrum. Will was sort of like, you know,
just a regular guy. And then the other guy was just like,
oh my God. Right.
Singing my lines. No, I didn't. I thought that that guy was actually good.
Right? Oh, why do I answer these fucking questions? You know,
all it does it just expose our fucking stupid. I am. Um, so anyways, he says,
so do you still think after seeing the gay soldiers in the news and the boring
normal gay marriage activist? Dude, I don't think that nobody thinks that.
I actually, some people think that. No, I don't think that. All right.
I'm just breaking balls there. Twinkle toes, um,
are the only gay guys y just gonna keep reading the rest of this for whatever
fucking reason. Or the only gay guys who have been out to your, uh,
out to you. Really just hairdressers in interior decorate. Sir,
how many examples are you going to give me?
All right. Papa. Papa. Okay. I'm done with that. No,
I don't think they're all like that. All right. So this is what I tell you.
Yeah, I understand that,
that some of you guys look like Mike Ditka add a act like Mike Decca yet,
you know, don't like Mike Dick go for the same reasons I do.
I understand that. So I think a lot more people do understand that. Um,
you know, yeah. There's all kinds of stereotypes out there. All right.
Look for the red headed male. You know, you think, I don't want to be a fucking,
you know,
start an action movie and be the guy who knows every type of karate and kick the
shit out of people and shoot the gun.
Do you think that ever going to give that role to a fucking freckled faced
pasty, redheaded jackass like me than not?
All right.
Who am I going to be? I'm going to be the guy who needs to be rescued,
or the guy who's good with computers.
All right. We all got a fucking extra grind, sir. All right,
so maybe you were just checking in, maybe you just making sure, um,
you know, I didn't even get his joke, a really gay question. Like,
I'm going to say that question was getting, you see what he's doing.
He was like mocking me and showing a sense of humor at the same time.
You see that he was testing my intelligence while flirting. Um,
I had a gay question last week. I said, what do you call a group of gay men?
This gay guy says, evidently they're called a giggle.
A group of gay men are called a giggle. No, they're not.
There's no fucking way. All Gay guys call a group of gay men giggles.
You know who called it douchebags who happen to be gay?
I'm sure that they say that. A giggle.
F Go fucking blow someone.
Yeah.
Oh, I swear to God. If I was ever to have the charisma of a mass murderer,
that's who I would kill.
Douchebags all groups would be allowed to stay around,
but you would have to prove to me that you weren't a douchebag.
And if you then who would you make fun of?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].